hey guys Pete here today we're going to
talk about dougie now this does have
spoilers for episodes 3 & 4 so if you
haven't seen those yet you will want to
come back and watch this after you see
those two episodes and while I was
putting this together I realized that
it's it's going to be a two-parter in
this part we're going to talk about what
we know about dougie and his short
lifespan on the show and then I'm going
to pose some questions that I'm thinking
about and I want to get some feedback
from you guys so dougie is a character
that doesn't last very long on screen in
episode 3 look at what we learned about
him in his short introduction and then
how his existence is might be really
important to the rest of the story
Dougie appears for us at the confluence
of two events inside the same episode
right we see agent Cooper get
transported out of the machine room and
we see evil coop or mr. see whatever you
like to call him
I like evil too and I will use that from
for consistency's sake but I know a lot
of people refer to him as mr. C you see
him fighting off sickness after wrecking
his car at exactly 253 p.m. we get a
shot of a sign for Rancho Rosa of states
in what looks like Las Vegas roses the
Spanish word for the color pink so
literal translation would be the pink
Ranch Estates Rancho Rosa is also the
production company Lynch and frost
created for Twin Peaks
dougies played by Cal McLaughlin
obviously but they added some padding to
make him look heavy and what looks like
a bad wig so dougie basically looks like
an agent Cooper who's let himself go we
assume that dougie is most likely a real
estate agent because when we meet him
he's with an escort inside an unoccupied
house in Rancho Rosa that has a for sale
sign outside the escort Jade is naked in
receiving her payment even though Dougie
is practically fully dressed besides his
coat and she's butting up buttoning up
his top button or whatever and before
she gets up to take a shower she asked
him what's wrong
his arm he says he doesn't know it fell
asleep and that it feels kind of tingly
something along those lines and those
turned out to be the only words he
speaks outside of the red broom as he
gets up from the bed we see hit that his
limp arm is wearing the green I'll cave
ring after he puts his jacket on he
starts to get ill and we get a cutscene
too evil coupe who's going through the
same thing more or less dougie crawls
through the house fails to get Jade's
attention and then gets sick on the rug
as we see the red curtain appear he then
disappears and we realize all three of
these coupe character sequences are
happening at the same time evil coupe
sees him appear in the red room an agent
Cooper passes through the electrical
outlet on the wall to switch places with
dougie in the red room when he appears
dougie is confused as to where he is and
what's going on mike is there and he
explains that someone manufactured
dougie for a purpose and that seems to
have been fulfilled
we then see Doug youth demise his arm
shrinks until the ringing falls off his
head disappears we see a gold orb and
then a gray mass that looks like it's
trying to hold on to the orb before it
disappeared and at the end all that's
left of dougie is a physical golden
sphere on the chair and the ring that's
on the floor
of course the orbit or the sphere came
from him and the ring is already been in
it's already existed in the universe in
the timeline we see that 253 passes and
evil coupe remains where he was out in
the mountains or a South Dakota
agent Cooper who is a lot worse for the
wear it's now in Dougie's place inside
the house in Las Vegas and Dougie has
been reduced to that golden pearl that's
the visual evidence that we have that's
all of what we saw we can piece it
together that they all happened at the
same time because it's pretty
straightforward
other than being presented in a
nonlinear fashion Mike helps us out by
telling us dougie has been manufactured
and that he served his
purpose and that I don't think is very
confusing
pretty straightforward really like evil
coupe created dougie as a decoy or
replacement so that when he was supposed
to switch back with the original Cooper
at 2:53 remember the arm told Cooper and
Mike about this number which we realized
is the time when that all happened
dougie would go back to the lodge a
agent Cooper would come out but evil
Cooper would also be able to stay out in
the real world while this part of the
story is easy enough to piece together
it brings up about a thousand other
questions primarily if dougie was
manufactured how long ago was he brought
into existence I mean he has a job a
wife a child and a career not to mention
that Jade and the guy in that he runs
into in the casinos seemed to have liked
they seemed already known they've known
him from before so going from there this
is what we'll explore in the second part
of this video I think Dougie's purpose
was clear but I could be wrong
anything is possible right so first
things first let me know in the comments
if we're on the same page as far as that
goes then we have to think about the
implications of Dougie's creation /
existence and these are the things that
come to mind for me so you can tell me
your ideas about these or any other
questions you might have or theories or
anything else about what's actually
going on here now the initial thing
that's a little bit of a wrinkle is that
the arms doppelganger obviously was
working against Mike and the arm itself
they sent Cooper out agent Cooper out
and the arms doppelganger changed his
course for lack of any better
explanation right so that's easy enough
to explain away the arms doppelganger
would be working with evil Cooper the
next thing that comes up is Jade Jade is
obviously hired by dougie she's a
prostitute and he pays her for her
services what's really kind of out of
place about Jade though is that even
though when she comes back after hearing
this really loud noise she points out
the fact that
looks totally different and is wearing
different clothes and that possibly he's
sick but she doesn't seem that bothered
about it
and this also could be explained away in
the sense that she's there to perform a
service she's done with that naturally
she just wants to get back to her life I
mean I can't say that I understand how
the mind of a sex worker operates but in
any job that I've ever had that is a
contract or whatever I want to complete
it get paid and move on so she may just
not really want to get involved with
dougie any more than what she already
has the next people we see who are also
hired for to perform a service are the
would-be assassins that are outside
waiting when the actual Cooper and
uglies place leaves with Jade right they
seem to want to kill dougie we presume
that he would you know he must know
somebody money and that you know they're
ready to punch his clock or punch his
ticket right but then after all of the
casino stuff we meet dougies wife and
son and they seem a little bit odd to
dougie
doesn't seem to be the brightest guy in
the short things that we've heard him
say especially in the Red Room itself he
just sort of seems to be like whoa
what's going on and then disappears but
his wife is either super super
understanding and also just really
caught up in her own life to not really
pay that much attention or there's a
pattern here that is very similar to
what Jade did yeah there's something
wrong but she doesn't really want to be
bothered with it so that's definitely
strange right and then we have this guy
mr. Todd who we know is located in Las
Vegas and he mentions after giving a
stack of cash to his assistant tell her
she has the job now you can connect some
dots here maybe and say mr. Todd was
talking about the person who is
portraying either Jade the escort or
Dougie's wife I don't think any of this
stuff is clear and I think that's what
you know I want to hear about
from you guys something's off we know
that there's something off with coop
being basically brain-dead but still
making his way around and the casino
scene I'm not going to get into real
deeply here but there is someone who
analyzed the sound on reddit and said
that the sounds that the giant plays for
Cooper are slot machine sounds so the
giant sends Cooper away he ends up in a
casino taking the place of this guy
dougie and then he gets hints as to how
to make a bunch of money really quickly
so it seems like there's two forces at
play here right now another thing I've
seen mentioned unrelated to any of that
was the bodies in Ruth Davenport's place
are those somehow related to the
creation or the manufacturer of dougie
that's certainly something to think
about but I don't know that there's any
solid evidence except for that we know
evil Cooper was in some way involved
with everything that went down in South
Dakota
another thing that pops up and I thought
about this today whenever I was
relooking at the Dougy disappearance
scene in that gold or someone had
commented on my glass pit box video that
there was a gold orb that we see before
we see the monster in the box so I went
back and looked at that and sure enough
there is now we see this gray mass which
is probably some sort of evil force
that's put into dougie by the man who
created them evil coupe we see that kind
of hold on try to hold on to that orb
and then disappear in the box we see
this monster it looks like there's a
gold ore floating above its hands and
then that disappears and that would
actually fit into the timeline that the
thing in the box could be this grey
thing that was inside dougie it's now
been released and it went out through
the box so that's totally new I don't
know I haven't seen anybody else talking
about that but that popped out to me
whenever I thought about that comment
that that someone made about the gold or
and then we have the Machine room which
I'm going to make a separate video about
some people are calling that the mob
zone
yeah the the part at the beginning of
this episode when we see Cooper get
transported through the electricity back
into the real world and since I'm going
to make another video I'll just talk
about it there but obviously there are
parallels to the first machine that coop
sees and evil coop and then you know
things get switched up and the second
machine that he sees that he actually
passes through is in fact taking him to
replace dougie so yeah there's a lot of
stuff related to this guy dougie who
only had a short run in the TV show
itself and I really want to hear you
guys his thoughts I'll be putting out
part two of this later in the week
before episode 5 comes out I am also
working on the part for recap and review
which will come out right after this and
at the same time that they that everyone
gets to see sewed floor and then like I
said I'll be doing a machine room thing
where we look at that a little bit
closer so any questions comments or
anything else we leave them on those
videos or on this video check out my
other videos if you haven't seen them I
did recaps for episode 1 episode 3
question and answer for episodes 1 & 2
or parts 1 & 2 and we'll be following
that up with Q&A s for episode 3 and
episode 4 so check back soon thanks for
watching I'll talk to you again